more than 32 million Americans are under
a severe weather threat this morning as
a powerful storm sweeps across the south
the system is threatening to unleash
damaging winds tornadoes hail and flash
flooding in more than a dozen states
multiple tornadoes were spotted
throughout the Texas Panhandle yesterday
Omar Villafranca is in Hobart Oklahoma
were a big tornado hit overnight Omar
good morning good morning these storms
were moving very very fast and the roof
and wall this building was just ripped
off it's somewhere down the road in the
middle there in the rubble you might be
able to see there's a boat this storm
happened at night meteorologists were
actually trying to track a tornado that
was on the ground and the only way they
could see it was in between flashes of
lightning in front of us a powerful
tornado ripped through Southwest
Oklahoma overnight and was on the ground
for roughly 20 miles it knocked out
power for hundreds and damaged some
buildings but narrowly missed bigger
towns and no one was injured heavy rain
from the same storm system hammered
Houston yesterday hitting areas that
were devastated by hurricane Harvey in
2017 the storm turned streets into
rivers leaving hundreds of drivers
stranded for hours it was getting bad
bad I know it was it will get this bad
the storm dumped as much as 15 inches of
rain south of Houston Fort Bend County
issued a disaster declaration for flash
flooding and in Sugar Land all major
roads were impassable I'm stressed out
so it's just off emergency crews
evacuated people from homes and used
rescue boats to reach others who were
trapped north of Houston some school
buses got stuck in rising floodwaters
this one tipped over with kids on board
they were all rescued some schools held
hundreds of students into the night
until water levels dropped enough for
parents to pick them up and they started
walking us in and we've been in since
about three o'clock the water is
receding in Houston but there is more
rain in their forecast in fact they
could see another six inches of rain by
the end of the week
John Amara thank you